ça fait plusieurs vidéos que j'insiste
sur tout ce qui peut aller mal quand on
met en place des mauvaises règles
d'interaction entre des individus
égoïstes
le problème c'est que bien souvent les
règles d'interaction conduisent à des
incentives immoraux et que les
comportements immoraux poste ensuite
conduire à une crise financière un
énorme prix de l'anarchie ou à de la
discrimination
c'est tout le problème d'une sous
discipline de la théorie des jeux qu'on
appelle la théorie de la conception de
mécanismes mécanisme design en anglais
et qui aura gagné de nombreux prix nobel
au cours de la dernière décennie
et bien aujourd'hui on va parler de
l'inde et saint graal de cette théorie
le mécanisme vcg du nom des économistes
vie craie clark est grosse
à l'instar du scrutin de condorcet
randomisés dont on a parlé dans
l'épisode 5 au sujet duquel mme sophie a
brillamment philosopher on va construire
le mécanisme vcg à partir d'un principe
philosophiquement élégant et naturel et
on découvrira seulement ensuite tout
étonné que l'élégance du mécanisme vcg
lui confère des propriétés remarquables
à la fois en termes d'initiatives
compatibilité et d'issues socialement
optimale
mais avant d'en arriver là considérons
un exemple
imaginons qu'un département cherche à
construire un nouveau réseau routier
pour mieux connectés cinq villes et
villages du coin
le problème c'est qu'il existe plusieurs
réseaux routiers possible l'un d'eux
fait du petit village du milieu le
carrefour de tout le département
les autres privilégient la grande ville
excentré et un autre réseau est un
dessin d'un bonhomme à la tête en bas
question comment choisir le réseau
routier à construire le problème c'est
que les préférences des différents
villages diffère le village du milieu
préférera le premier réseau pts 10 que
la grande ville pourrait préférer le
troisième réseau comment prendre une
décision qui convienne à tous les
villages
alors bien sûr on pourra utiliser
n'importe quel des scrutins que l'on a
vu au début de cette série notamment
bien sûr le scrutin de condorcet
randomisés mais le mécanisme vcg va
s'autoriser quelque chose que les
scrutins démocratiques s'interdisent
pour plus d'équité entre les parties
prenantes pourquoi ne pas faire payer
ceux qui profitent de la décision finale
et ainsi compenser financièrement ceux
pour qui la décision finale est
embêtante
et oui en faisant ça même les moins
heureux ne seront pas trop malheureux
mais du coup comment déterminer ces
compensations financières et bien l'idée
de génie du mécanisme vcg c'est de faire
payer à chacun le coup que sa présence
impute au bien être social des autres
par exemple peut-être que si la grande
ville n'avait pas son mot à dire sur la
construction du réseau routier alors les
autres villes se seraient mis d'accord
pour le réseau routier 1
mais le fait que la grande ville
prennent part à la décision a peut-être
forcé les autres villes à s'accorder sur
le réseau routier 3 du coup la présence
de la grande ville a modifié la décision
qui l'a fait passer de 1 à 3 certes ça
arrange peut-être d'autres villes mais
vu que les autres villes auraient décidé
un en l'absence de la grande ville ou
sans que l'ensemble des villes autre que
la grande ville
ia perdure en passant de 1 à 3 et bien
le mécanisme vcg propose de forcer la
grande ville à payer le déficit de
bonheur de ses autres villes lorsque
l'on force ces autres villes à passer de
1 à 3
le mécanisme vcg force la grande ville à
payer le coût que sa présence impute aux
autres villes et le mécanisme vcg va
faire de même pour toutes les autres
villes
prenons un autre exemple pour être sûr
de comprendre cela supposons que en
l'absence du petit village du milieu
décision socialement optimale aurait été
le réseau routier 3 tout comme elle l'a
été en présence du village du milieu
alors ça veut dire que la présence du
village du milieu n'a aucun effet sur la
prise de décision et donc en particulier
sa présence d'un put aucun coup aux
autres villes le mécanisme vcg ne fera
donc rien payé au village du milieu
j'insiste une des rares fois sur
l'intuition fondamentale derrière vcg
chacun paie le coup que sa présence
impute au bien-être des autres
voyons maintenant comment ça marche dans
les détails pour pouvoir appliquer le
mécanisme vcg il nous faut savoir ce que
les parties prenantes serait prête à
payer pour telle ou telle autre réseau
routier par exemple la grande ville sera
peut-être prête à payer 2 millions
d'euros pour le réseau 1,14 million
paulo réseau 2 et 16 millions pour leurs
réseaux 3 le village du milieu sera
peut-être prêt à payer 20 millions 1
millions et 4 millions et ainsi de suite
pour les autres villes avec ce tableau
de chiffres on peut aisément calculer
les valeurs total attribué au réseau
routier globale par l'ensemble de toutes
les villes
on constate alors que le réseau 3 est
celui qui a globalement le plus de
valeur avec une valeur globale de 42
millions ou dit autrement le réseau 3
est socialement optimale c'est donc lui
qu'il faut construire ont choisi sont
toujours la décision qui a le plus de
valeur globale vcg garantit ainsi de
prendre une décision socialement
optimale pour savoir combien doit payer
la grande ville il faut voir ce qu'il se
passe en son absence
en son absence c'est maintenant le
réseau un qui aurait été construit sa
valeur totale aurait alors été de 35
millions contre les 26 millions que
représente le réseau 3 pour les villes
autre que la grande ville la présence de
la grande ville fait donc diminuer la
valeur de la décision collective pour
les autres villes de 35 millions à 26
millions autrement dit le couple la
présence de la grande ville impute aux
hôtes est égal à 9 millions d'euros
c'est ce montant que le mécanisme vcg
imposera à la grande ville de même un
raisonnement similaire montre qu'en
l'absence de la seconde plus grande
ville c'est le réseau un qui aura été
construit le coup que la présence de la
seconde plus grande ville impute aux
autres villes sera alors de 3 millions
d'euros
et je vous laisse vérifier qu en
revanche l'absence des autres villes ne
modifie pas l'optimalité social du
réseau 3 ce qui implique que les autres
villes
on rien à payer selon le mécanisme vcg
j'espère que vous avez bien compris le
principe de bcg vcg prend une décision
socialement optimale et force chacun à
payer le coût que sa présence impute au
bien-être social des autres ça en soit
c'est philosophiquement satisfaisant
mais le génie de bcg
c'est surtout qu'il est incentive
compatibles et ça c'est une propriété
absolument remarquable est crucial comme
on l'a vu dans l'épisode 18
contrairement au cas de beaucoup de
mécanismes toutes parties prenantes de
bcg a toujours intérêt à révéler
honnêtement ce qu'ils pensent vraiment
des différentes alternatives
et oui supposer que la grande ville
sache exactement ce qu'ont annoncé les
autres villes elle sait donc que si elle
fait basculer la décision finale vers le
réseau 3 alors elle devra payer 9
millions d'euros
or la grande ville fera basculer la
décision finale vers le réseau 3 si et
seulement si elle dit attribuer une
valeur aux réseaux 3 qui est neuf
millions d'euros ou plus que la valeur
qu'elle dit attribué au réseau 1
du coup si la grande ville attribue
effectivement une valeur aux réseaux 3
qui est neuf millions ou plus que la
valeur qu'elle attribue aux réseaux 1
elle aura alors tout intérêt à révéler
ses préférences honnêtement pour faire
basculer la décision finale vers le
réseau 3 et si ce n'est pas le cas elle
aura également tout intérêt à révéler
honnêtement ses préférences sachant que
de toute façon elle n'affectera pas la
décision finale et n'imputera donc aucun
coup ou bien être des autres
et d'ailleurs ce raisonnement il tient
peu importe ce que les autres villes ont
annoncé
on dit que l'honnêteté dans le mécanisme
vcg est une stratégie dominante ou dit
encore autrement
le miracle de wc j'ai c'est d'être à la
fois naturel socialement optimale et
incentive compatibles un vrai bijou de
la théorie des jeux forum
le mécanisme le vcg a également ses
limites en particulier il est très
difficile de savoir à l'avancé quel est
le montant qui sera collecté via avait
séché et le problème c'est que l'on ne
peut pas modifier les différents
montants que les différentes parties
prenantes devront payer sans violer
incentive compatibility alors ce qui
aurait pu être fait c'est qu'on aura pu
collecter a priori une taxe sur toutes
les villes houn obtiendrait alors une
variante du mécanisme vcg appelé
mécanisme de crosse
mais le problème c'est que dès lors
certaines villes peuvent se sentir les
dans le sens où ce qu'ils auront payé
risque d'être supérieurs à ce qu'ils
sont effectivement prêts à payer pour le
réseau routier choisi on dit que le
mécanisme ainsi construit peut violer la
rationalité individuelle mais en
pratique ça peut conduire une ville à
sentir que le département lui pompe
toutes ces richesses sans rien en retour
et ainsi conduire un mouvement
indépendantiste de la ville bref comme
j'espère vous l'avoir fait comprendre
construire des mécanismes avec des
bonnes propriétés
c'est un problème mathématique très
difficile et la recherche mathématique
dans ce domaine et foisonnant par
exemple en 2012
saïda ce cas là qu'ils aient weinberg
prouve un merveilleux théorème qui
permet de réduire tout problème de
conception de mécanismes bayésiens un
problème d'optimisation sans contrainte
d incentive compatible itil ceci étant
dit même si le mécanisme le vcg lui
n'est pas la solution à tous les
problèmes en particulier pour s'assurer
de l'équilibré des budgets vcg demeure
néanmoins une brillante solution pour
prendre des décisions socialement
optimale tout en réussissant le tour de
force de garantir que les parties
prenantes auront tout intérêt à
participer honnêtement révélant leurs
vrais préférence et ça c'est déjà un
truc de malade
l'anr fin on a parlé de l'enchère de
mercenaires et nex ne me demande plus de
précisions sur cette enchère de meilleur
sonne comme un ça fonctionne vraiment
alors j'ai pas voulu être trop technique
dans la vidéo précédente notamment pas
trop rentrer dans les détails de
qu'est-ce qu'une croyance barisienne
puisqu'il faut absolument avoir compris
ça pour bien comprendre l'enchère de
manière sonne il avoue renvoie vers le
cours de bourse ra game gear online de
matthew jackson et d'autres professeurs
qui donnent pas mal d'exemples également
pour mieux expliquer l'enchère moi je
trouve personnellement que
malheureusement les exemples aide pas
forcément à vraiment comprendre
l'enchère elle même de ce procès que je
n'ai pas présenté une façon de
comprendre l'enchère demeure sonne c'est
qu'une certaine manière on va associer
aux prix annoncés par les différents
acheteurs une évaluation verte virtuel
donc c'est un autre nombre réel qui va
être la vraie compétition à faire une
compétition entre acheteurs sur des
valeurs virtuelles d'évaluation virtuel
poté les termes de personnes et ensuite
on a fait qu'ils n'ont cher au second
prix à ces évaluations vers virtuel mais
pour déterminer le prix que la personne
va vraiment payé va falloir qu'on
regarde du coup le second prix annoncés
en termes d'évaluation virtuel et qu'on
retraduit ça en termes de prix
le truc c'est que le calcul de la
validation virtuelle à partir du prix
annoncé par chaque acheteur potentiel
dépend de la créance base yens que l'on
a sur chacun des affaires des points de
ce qu'on croit que l'acheteur est
vraiment prêt à payer une manière dont
ces calculs et bompas et c'est cette
formule assez compliqué difficile
d'expliquer à ces imams difficile
d'avoir une bonne intuition de ce que
c'est pour moi personnellement je suis
pas une très bonne intuition de ce que
ça veut dire
cette expression là donc malheureuses
ont expliqué les vrais détails dans le
cher de ma personne c'est pas facile
et du coup j'ai préféré essayer de
donner une intuition de ce qui se passe
vraiment à savoir l'utilisation des
croyances païennes pour pouvoir
déterminer un prix de réserve pour
chacun les acheteurs
ensuite ne pas hésiter à créer une
compétition à distance des prix en
menaçant si on est le vendeur de vendre
à celui qui offre moins parce que l'on
croit que celui qui offre au moins dix
vraiment ce qui lèverait pas billets
alors que peut-être que l'autre qui
offre plus est peut-être en train de
profiter du fait qu'il y ait peu de
concurrence pas pour lui c'est que lui
donne du coup des incentives ne pas
annoncer ce qui est vraiment frapper
nous pour éviter cela un vendeur de
recherche de meilleurs sonne ne va pas
forcément vendre à celui qui offre le
plus enex nous demande aussi ce qui se
passe quand il ya plusieurs vendeurs
alors si à plusieurs vendeurs le
problème devient beaucoup beaucoup plus
compliqué et on voit aujourd'hui à ma
connaissance en tout cas un point qui
n'est pas résolu alors poule amblard met
en avant le cas de l'offre et la demande
en fait l'offre et la demande c'est un
modèle qui correspond à l'information
parfaite et la vraie difficulté des
enchères notamment la meilleure sonne et
des négociations en général c'est le
fait que l'information est incomplète et
du coup les questions qui se sont posées
personnes notamment sait comment est ce
qu'on fait lorsque l'information est
incomplète quelle est la meilleure façon
de vendre un bien ou d'acheter un bien
d'ailleurs acheteurs et vendeurs ce sont
des rôles assez symétrique
s'il ya un acheteur et beaucoup de
vendeurs il peut appliquer l'enchère de
meilleures années par exemple acheté
auprès d'un vendeur qui vend plus cher
parce qu'ils pensent que d'autres
vendeurs qui vendent moins cher annonce
pas vraiment le vrai prix auquel ils
sont prêts à vendre donc un acheteur
plusieurs vendeurs ça marche
un vendeur plusieurs acteurs seront
marche bien mais plusieurs acheteurs
plusieurs vendeurs avec information
complète c'est un contexte beaucoup plus
difficile à résoudre
une autre remarque c'est que leur flair
de personnes celles enchères d'un seul
bien du coup on peut se demander comment
est ce qu'on fait pour vendre plusieurs
biens et ça c'est la question qui se
pose beaucoup on pratique notamment par
exemple pour vendre des bandes de
fréquences pour pouvoir y mettre en
quête je sais pas trop quoi plus les
enchères avec des milliards en jeu du
coup faut vraiment faire attention à ce
que l'on cherche se passe bien et j'ai
entendu dire que pour la vente des
fréquences aux états unis étaient en
train de faire appel à des chercheurs en
théorie des jeux de princeton si c'est
le cas c'est vraiment cool c'est que les
personnes ne dirigeante prennent bien en
compte les avancées de la recherche en
théorie des jeux et en particulier sont
bien conscients du problème des
incentives aprem que j'ai vu parfois
absent dans l'esprit de certaines
personnes qui par exemple travaillé sur
le marché de l'électricité californie
qui serait sûr de lui des preuves plus
d'optimisation et qui s'était pas posé
problème des intiatives ce que j'ai
trouvé assez dérangeante sachant que la
crise de l'excès cité a eu lieu des gens
qui fournit il ya quinze ans à cause
justement des problèmes de sept îles
bref le cas où il faut vendre plusieurs
biens c'est un problème aussi à très
intéressant de théorie des jeux qui a
été résolue du coup par le théorème de
saïda ce cas la crise et valberg
mais le problème c'est que leur solution
est quand même vachement compliqué pour
réussir à faire confiance à leur
algorithme ce n'est pas évident au
touquet la preuve est très difficile
très accessible à tout le monde tout cas
fait une centaine de pages sont les
toubous table et j'ai l'occasion
notamment d'assister à des séminaires
des parts eisenberg qui disait vraiment
que c'est un vrai problème en pratique
et du coup il se pose aussi la question
de trouver juste des mécanismes simples
faciles à expliquer facile à comprendre
pour lesquels on peut se convaincre
assez facilement qui sont enceintes
compatibles
ça pose aussi le problème de l'
expertise des gens qui vont prendre une
décision à moins qu'ils ont accepté de
mettre en place un algorithme qui vont
refuser de mettre place ces thèmes bien
si ces gens là sont capables de
comprendre petit peu l'algorithme enfin
professeur culture précieuse nous donne
un exemple assez amusant
de temps chers qu'ils appellent
apparemment l'enchère du diable ou mais
c est ce qui est amusant dans cette
enchère c'est que si on prend une
enchère où tout le monde doit payer tout
ce qui est annoncé à partir du moment où
les gens ont commencé à rentrer dans le
jeu et s'ils ont la possibilité de
surenchérir à chaque fois dans le jeu
alors ils ont toujours intérêt à
surenchérir
car ce qu' ils ont déjà payé en eau et
rajouter un petit peu plus bas ils
doivent payer juste c'est un petit peu
plus et du coup ça peut faire monter en
escalade et finalement il est possible
que les deux se retrouvent à payer une
fortune tout ça parce qu'ils n'ont pas
anticipé le fait initialement que les
sorcières allait grimper comme cela
alors bien sûr si on analyse et ça avec
la théorie des jeux de base dirais que
initialement il devait pouvoir anticiper
toute cette escalade au moment de miser
dès le début et que du coup on a pas
forcément misé des débuts autre chose
j'avais insisté en vidéo précédente que
en pratique les acheteurs potentiels ont
des biais cognitif et notamment si on
passe beaucoup de temps sur une enchère
au premier prix et conflits par la
perdre et marié un sentiment de temps
perdu quoi tu comme on attache beaucoup
plus d'importance aux pertes cog 1 on va
vouloir vraiment ne pas perdre ce qui va
conduire à surenchérir voir à payer plus
que ce qu'on était prêt à payer avant le
début de leur cher donc à cause des
biais cognitif ils sont plus longs chez
art premier prix en fête marche assez
bien en pratique puisque ça ça pousse
les gens à mettre plus que ce qu'ils
étaient prêts à payer avant l'enchère
est ce genre de phénomène bail est
totalement absent des modèles classiques
de théorie des jeux on prend pas en
compte parce que c'est juste trop
compliqué on sait pas comment prendre en
compte du coup on préfère faire des
modèles mathématiques simples sur lequel
on peut prouver des théorèmes plus
généralement dans cette série il ya pas
mal d'aspects psychologique et qui sont
complètement négligés parce que l'on
veut simplifier les modèles pour pouvoir
prouver l'étoile à leur sujet et bien
sûr du coup il faut prendre avec des
pincettes pas mal les choses qui sont
dans cette série même si le message
global et notamment sur l'importance des
incentives reste important à mon sens je
vous renvoie notamment vers l'épisode 9
que j'avais pas mal insisté sur ça mais
aussi sur les épisodes de 10 et 11 ans
j'avais parlé de psychologie j'espère
que j'avais aimé cette vidéo la
prochaine fois on va parler un peu plus
d'équité ou c'est déjà un mot que j'ai
vidéo mais dans la prochaine vidéo on va
carrément on parlait beaucoup plus
d'équité et comment est-ce qu'on peut
étudier ça dans tant de vue mathématique
si vous avez aimé cet épisode concerne
le lac est le commentaire de partage et
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes merci aux
tipa power dont et j'espère que vous
serez là la prochaine fois nous en
étudions différentes civilisations a
trouvé des monnaies très diverses des
coquillages des plumes des morceaux de
bois la valeur que l'on donne à l'argent
repose uniquement sur la confiance que
l'on accorde au système